Mortal Kombat I thought we were done
with Mortal Kombat 11 I'm not gonna lie
I thought it was like okay Mortal Kombat
11 is done so now we're gonna start
rolling out some injustice three news
nope guess not so we just got a trailer
from Mortal Kombat 11 aftermath so
Mortal Kombat aftermath is DLC it's a
DLC story campaign plus DLC characters
plus well I guess it's a free patch for
pit fatalities and friendships are
coming back and I've seen this comment
in the comments section of the trailer
and I completely agree when Terminator
dies in that fashion he has to do the
thumbs up of all the movie references in
the Mortal Kombat games including but
not limited to Mortal Kombat 11 you
can't tell me they haven't thought of
that beam eyes a little detail so not
only are we getting more DLC characters
with Mortal Kombat aftermath but we're
also we get a new campaign story it
follows Shang soon Shang seems like no
you did the wreck Kong to the retcon but
you retcon wrong so we've got a wreck on
your retcon to actually be on the right
retcon which is the end of MK 11 also
like I said all you're gonna do is like
make alternate timelines and that one
runs the course and backs you into a
corner alright we'll make an alternate
timeline so I got MK 12 is gonna be that
now we're not even at MK 12 yet we're
gonna I guess fix that now which you
know means what you already knew which
is characters who die they're not dead
they never are it's like which makes it
feel like there are less stakes when it
comes to MK deaths so it appears the DLC
characters were getting were part of the
DLC leaked list that came out like the
of the DLC characters that were leaked
before the DLC characters actually came
out initially where all the characters
we actually did get plus Fujin and sheba
and now Fujin and Shiva are DLC
characters in here and Robocop I don't
know it was amazing to me is ash from
Evil Dead gonna be in here cuz it was
one of the rumored DLC characters before
we will say let us stop and appreciate
the fact that in MKX we got alien vs.
predator and now in Mortal Kombat 11 we
have robocop vs terminators Captain Kirk
Darth Vader lope and Superman in every
single Power Ranger bill S Preston and
Theodore Logan Spock the rock and Hulk
Hogan I have to finish it when it starts
it's just a thing you know it actually
makes me really pumped about this is
we're getting curry Hiroyuki Tagawa as a
Shang soon performance he voices Shang
soon as the DLC character and MK 11 he's
already there but it's not a story we're
actually getting Shang soon from the
movie doing manipulative shanks and
things played by the
who plays him in the movie who was
amazing as him in the movie I know he
played Shing suing an MK legacy I'm just
saying here he's gonna be doing a lot
more I know I'm pumped to see that and I
can say that about Mortal Kombat 11 more
will come at 11 has had some legs
whereas initially when Mortal Kombat 11
came out I preferred X over 11 and I
think I'm better at X well for the most
part the DLC characters really brought
it home for me the DLC characters and
Mortal Kombat 11 they're amazing for the
most part terminators my least favorite
of the DLC characters but is because I
just don't play as him I just find him
to be a little clunky Terminator and
night wolf for the two I just played as
least but everyone else I put many hours
into them did all of their towers shank
soon was first remains one of my
favorites Joker I felt like they did my
boy justice not only did he play well
not only was he really aggressive but he
was also really unpredictable you feel
like god am I gonna release it I mean
I'll release it now spawn was epic voice
by Keith David from the HBO series and
it's what I'm talking about I like the
fact that they they went that extra mile
you can feel like they were like no
Keith David's necessary to voice spawn
and Sindel became my main like if I
needed to dispatch a difficult tower
very quickly I just used epic screaming
milf and got it done which if we are
going on alternate timelines and
reckoning the retcons from the original
retcons come and go ahead and wreak on
the fact that she's a dick now I mean I
like Sindel is a tragic character where
she's good but she's just cursed with
evil energy and evil magic so that makes
her bad but in there she's still a good
person and it's the quest to release her
from those shackles but in MK 11 they're
like nah she's just always been an
[ __ ] I didn't like that as much so if
you're gonna doing a wreck on anything
gonna wreck on that I will say with this
DLC like most all DLC you line up the
$60 package you initially got and then
you have this DLC that's $40 and the
ratio doesn't seem right it's not like
we're getting 2/3 the content of the
initial release I feel like we're
getting much less so I've really the
deal so you should be much less that's
always how DLC is and that's probably
why people hate DLC so we'll see if
these initial three DLC characters are
all we get on top of the story are we
getting more crypts stuff are we getting
more DLC characters rolled as like now
you already paid for it there
now if you paid for it so we'll see what
they do to make the $40 price point
worth it but I can definitely say Mortal
Kombat 11 has kept me engaged and kept
me coming back because of the trickle of
DLC characters they've had thus far I
guess that's why I'm rolling with this
DLC trickle in a world where there's so
much entertainment just pining for our
attention Mortal Kombat 11 has kept me
engaged for far longer than I thought it
was going to I have definitely gotten my
money's worth
initial release DLC and beyond what the
pit fatalities and friendships those are
a free patch so I mean I appreciate that
you're at least getting some new content
if you just want to be like I'll hold
off for the super duper ultra super
Edition if they're definitely most
certainly gonna come out with so seeing
a trailer from Mortal Kombat aftermath I
gotta say in the words of a great leader
a surprise to be sure but a welcome one
or is it the trailer for Mortal Kombat
aftermath have you seen it what do you
think about it what do you think of all
the DLC characters that we're getting
stage fatalities friendships more
characters who would you like to see in
Mortal Kombat 11 whatever you think of
all of that comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]